good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday it is obviously
friday which is normally like a super
joyous occasion but we are being blessed
in the studio with the presence of bruno
bruno sweets is here first time ever i
said i was going to try and bring him
this week and then it was friday and i
was like
i'm a woman of my word bruno let's go
it's really hard like i do not envy we
used to have this with theo it's like
the running around the pooping it's like
it's a full-time job when you're
literally trying to do your full-time
job right he got here
he needed to poop i could like tell he
was about to go right you know right
where theo looked back at it yeah she's
staying right between our feet so i took
him over yonder i put down a paper towel
i was like let's see how smart this guy
is pooped right on the paper towel right
in the trash
and now he's like he's he's as good as
you can ask for a puppy
i did um like now need to kill myself
because i stepped on his foot yeah
with my big [ __ ] boots and he was
just like i didn't even know he was
behind me and like now i'm sorry i have
to die so this will be my last show i
know
you know he really gets underfoot and
that little yellow
it's happened to me so many times that
like i don't fault you that little yelp
though like
sends me to a dark place like and you
know what i feel like
one day it'll happen to him so when it
actually really hurts so bad
and he'll learn something from it and
he'll stop getting under foot
oh no that's see that's the difference
and this is what me and ben always say
it's like we love theo so much but like
it is frustrating to love something so
much and they can really never tell you
that they love you back
or speak or learn and it's frustrating
and that's the difference between like
the love you have
for a baby and the love you have for a
dog it's like the baby eventually like
learns to
grow up and like the dog just doesn't
yeah but he learns some things like he's
a second genius he became a doctor and
he can't even you know technically
communicate with the patient right and
he has no borders
no he has no borders he's such a great
man i mean it's a it's a shame that in
order for bruno to be here it meant that
theo
had to take the day off especially
considering he stole the show yesterday
we had no idea by the way he got a
haircut last night just for today's show
but if we brought both of the dogs it
would have been pandemonium but you know
what
one day we they'll be in a place where
they can do that and we'll just have
like our whole litter here at the show
maybe knowles will be
coming too and that's like been our
dream yeah it has
um so today's obviously exciting for a
multitude of reasons bruno friday
but also we are able to not announce
quite yet
but give you a little sneak peek at our
holiday march collection which is coming
and you will have your items
in time for the holidays i'm just taking
a sip of my coffee aka dye pepsi
from our new toasty mug that's claudia
that's beautiful
and i'm just gonna send some text
messages from my new
phone case i haven't had a phone case in
months i'm literally so excited about
this phone case
and maybe i'll send some text from your
phone to claudia
ooh spooky phone cases
we're really excited we have new
sweatshirts we have new accessories
upcoming um i'll take my phone back now
that you did your little commercial
really exciting stuff so make sure you
are just keeping up with the toast on
instagram and listening to the podcast
to find out when you can get your merch
and how long shades we'll show you the
exclusives that's just a little taste we
wanted to give you a taste because we've
been seeing so many comments
of people
there's a taste wet your whistle we are
all over it just like we're all over
everything like the past five stories
today we have keeping up with the
kardashians and southern charm recaps
coming at you the season finale
of keeping up with the kardashians last
night was such a pleasure watching
two episodes of good television and then
having the night to myself i actually
started a book which i haven't read
a book that's not for the redheads since
i guess mariah carey but still that's
been like a month you know
i really hadn't read in so long but i'm
reading um my new my
second favorite author i said last night
on instagram she's my favorite author
but she's my second favorite
because my first favorite is claudia
ashrae oh yes did i not mention that i
am a published author
starting january 26 2021 um you know
usually it's like oh drake great
jackie's talking about her books again
like i could just like
daisy but now i'm like oh an opportunity
for me to promote my book
girl with no job the crazy beautiful
life of an instagram thirst monster
now available at many many real
retailers like barnes and noble
amazon tons of places audiobooks are
available for pre-order ebooks are
available for pre-order and i would
really appreciate all the possible
pre-orders because i have a goal
and i know a lot of people have goals
when it comes to books but mine is to
get into the airport because i just feel
like
that's a chic aesthetic and i can't
really get into the airport i think
unless i have like lots of pre-orders
because they're like oh my god this girl
she's so popular she's so famous
we got to put her in the hudson news or
msnbc store so i need you guys just to
head over to girlwithnojob.combook
or tap the link in my bio on instagram
tons of retailers canadian toasters i
got you guys too
maybe i can get to the canadian airports
all the links are in the link in my bio
check it out thanks
i'm done promoting for the day very very
good so yeah i'm just so excited that
it's friday
me too it's been it's been a big week
yeah it's been um
it's been a tough one i'm not gonna lie
yeah i just feel like at this point like
being alive is tough
it is so i can't really say that there
was anything like different or
particularly challenging about this up
week but just life man it's [ __ ] hard
it is but i have bruno sweets in my life
now and he has just been like the
biggest blessing
it's it's so wonderful so much work like
not gonna lie so
my whole life is changed but it's worth
every minute you know
and that does go away like it's just so
important to keep that in mind
when it's like the puppy months and
you're like oh my god like i need to
give this dog up like
just always keep in mind like the toughs
like that goes away and that's easy for
me to remember
because i see theo and i'm like
this is a perfect man this is what's
possible this is a dream
so he's a perfect man and he also like
even though he's a puppy and he has
energy and this and that he can be
annoying sometimes like
he's really the best thing like he's the
sweetest sweetest thing
that's why he's called bruno sweets i
call him bruno ocasio cortez i don't
know why but it just
really because we say bruno sweets
so that's where i'm going with the
nickname and that's that on that he's
named after all the nespretto flavors
right and that's why it's inspired me
oh dazio is my favorite and esprezzo
flavor
um espresso nespresso oh my gosh he's
burrowing i'm sorry
i thought he was peeing on your life i'm
sorry if he's making a lot of noise
today you guys like this is
i won't bring him again for a while but
i said i would bring him this week
people were asking
it's a woman of her work i didn't want
to let people down you know that's not
what we do here we lift people up
and if you're listening as a podcast and
bruno's bothering you then head over to
youtube because then the noises will
match with the actions
yeah he's being so cute it's like hard
to even be upset it is hard to be upset
but
don't worry i'll get there i'm kidding
can you hear him like just furrow you
know get his
bully stick oh he's totally fine he's
the sweetest thing um
we have a great show we do and i think
we should get right into it because
bruno's like never seen his mother at
work before
wow he's gonna be like so proud of you
oh my god i hope so i hope i can make
you proud
so without further oh my god i'm already
[ __ ] up
[Applause]
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and we have a brand new sponsor today
which i'm very excited about because the
sponsor of to this episode
is insert name here also known as inh
hair
a female founded la hair brand
specializing in ponytail extensions
hot tools wigs and general hair
amazingness i wore a bunch of their
clips actually on the show yesterday
um they make everything like start to
finish and
this is literally not even in my notes
but you know we're obsessed with like
pomades and products that get our
flyaways away they make an amazing
product that comes
like in a mascara tube that's meant to
just like
like slick down your flyaways or any
random like broken hairs that you have
like i have so many
best things i know and i love the idea
of it being like in a mascara too but
using that kind of brush it's great so
they have
hot tools i used their round brush blow
dryer yesterday
they have that new three prong butterfly
um
curling curling wand iron they just make
everything for your hair from start to
finish
their latest hot tool release which is
genius is called the insert blowout here
a new innovative hair drying brush
perfect for all hair types and can be
used daily
get the salon blow up blowout at home
for a fraction of the price
with nylon bristles three temperature
settings an led indicator and ceramic
titanium plates to protect your hair
insert blowout here will be your new bff
to be mentioned they're affordable too
inh offers quad pay which lets you which
lets you split your total cost into four
easy monthly payments so you can look
glamorous for as little as 15
down they also offer occasional discount
codes so be sure to follow them on all
their social media platforms and sign up
for their exclusive emails you don't
want to miss out you can also get color
matched for your ponytail extensions
today if you want to find your perfect
extension shade by dming them on
instagram
at insert name here and someone will
answer within an
hour and then you could start shopping
at inhair.com
they have shades for redheads too so
they're inclusive thank you ina chair
they gave us a 30 code because they know
a lot of our customers
a lot of their customers are toasters
but it's valid for a limited time only
so this is a great gift for someone or
if you're just looking to revamp your
hair
the code is toast at checkout you can
save while supplies last
30 that's again code toast at inhair.com
check it out love it sign on get great
hair
get great hair first story the big story
of the day
the weekend is set to headline the 2021
super bowl halftime show he says i'm
humbled honored and
ecstatic the news dropped yesterday that
the weekend will be headlining the
halftime show
at the super bowl lv i think that's 55
on february 7th in tampa bay florida
so we'll get to whether or not we think
this is a good selection but i just have
to say i thought that the um
the announcement for this was like so
low-key and weird like he just like
posted a picture on his instagram like
there was no like
hype i feel like usually this time last
year like we're always talking about
like it's going to be announcing yeah
and like there's articles written like
top five choices there was just like no
hype or buzz around this and then like i
saw him on instagram i thought he got
hacked
by like a pepsi sponsor it was just it
was very bizarre
marketing got it i heard the news from
zach like he saw it on his phone and
then told me so i didn't have to deal
with like the
way that it was delivered to me but yeah
i do agree it was very low
fanfare quiet pretty quiet and
i'm curious to hear what you think about
the choice i think the weeknd is
an amazing artist i wouldn't have
chosen him for the super bowl just based
on what we what you
the criteria the usual criteria for the
super bowl which is like albums and
albums of
and catalogs of music you know an artist
that sort of
bridges generations i think that he's an
amazing talent i think a lot of people
will be
blown away by the show that he does put
on but i do think that there are some
people
who might not even know who he is that's
possible but i do want to say like that
criteria that the super bowl has had for
like years
is actually they are running out of
people like beyonce's literally done it
like five times in the last 10 years
coldplay bruno mars like they are
running out of people so like their
criteria is actually really
strict like and i don't know how much
longer they can go on
many artists that bridge generations
right and have catalogs and catalogs of
music so now they're choosing
contemporary artists
that i personally think have like the
talent and the chops
to entertain everyone yeah so even if
you didn't know this person or their
music before
i mean i think he has so many hits that
like it'll you know
ring a bell for people but even if you
weren't like a major
fan before you will become one and
i actually do think not that there's
tons of like older people listening
to the weekend but his music style and
sound i can't feel my face
it's very like michael jackson like i
actually think blinding lights is
like an amazing song and it's very it's
it's
temporary but it's universal so i
actually think this is a very good
choice and i also think like given the
year we're coming off of especially with
like
so much controversy in the nfl like to
have a black performer is wonderful
so i actually i wouldn't have ever chose
him but i'm not mad about it
i'm not mad about it i was definitely
surprised by the choice but the more
that i think about it
i think it's like a new direction which
they needed for the halftime show
which is i'm always here for a new
direction yeah and i'm always here for
the new direction
and you know what if one direction wants
to come on with the weekend like i
wouldn't be
imagine and if the um glee club wants to
come on
with a different um picture with a
different teacher other than mr shu
well can i just say that i like that
this half time should and usually they
do bring on like a second or third act
i think it should be the weekend and the
new directions i mean
honestly like at the peak of glee the
fact that like they never did the
halftime show like it would have been
iconic they bridge generations they sing
songs
from all different decades like i
actually think like all jokes aside
at the height of glee's face and they
had come when they were on tour if they
had come on it wouldn't have been crazy
but i'm not like shocked that nobody
else
no but like it would have been iconic
like truly but can i just say like
earlier in the week we reported that
matthew morrison is going to be
the grinch on the nbc's reenactment of
the grinch blah blah
and while the news was obviously
devastating for us in the
uh matthew morrison as a war criminal
fan club
um can i just say the content like
that's now being
pushed around because he's back in the
news is so funny
and people are just like tagging me and
like matthew morrison is being cringy
tick tocks
so while i'm upset that he is going to
ruin christmas i'm actually glad because
it brought us all this content
right and it's really bringing the
matthew mars and haters together
yeah no we are a strong united front and
people reached out to me just saying you
know
you know i can't really talk about this
with any of my friends and just like
hearing you on the podcast
made me feel like less alone and i just
that's what i
always want to be for people is is a
voice for the voiceless
yeah everybody's like that's beautiful
we are yeah
so i wonder sorry if all the backlash on
matthew martin being announced as the
grinch like
has made nbc reconsider no i think
there's already like a trailer out for
it like i think it's happening it's too
late
it's too late it sucks but i think it's
good for them too like you know
their people are talking that's true and
so that's always true that's always one
what you want like people are talking
about the weekend and
i think it'll be exciting and also i'm
going to assume that he's going to bring
at least
one other person or artist or group out
who does he collabs with
like on his songs maybe like they have
one song but it's her
oh but that's like a really old scene i
know but um you never know no that'd be
cool
yeah has ari ever done it no that's
weird yeah but she's another one who's
like i could see her one day doing it
but i think right now it would be a very
contemporary choice
see no i think maybe that's the problem
that they have
and like ariana grande should be the one
to do it she's the biggest pop star in
the world so if she doesn't fit their
criteria like your criteria sucks like
make some changes
and i actually think that they are
because there are only so many
lady gagas there are only so many
beyonce's brutal mars like once in a
once in a generation
and who also happened to have like pop
music like adele could do it but like
everyone would be crying like yeah
is about to make a leap for it
what do you think about this news he's
like my name said bruno mars should be
there
i mean if bruno mars did it every year
like i would literally be the biggest
fan of
football no totally but the weekend put
out a statement saying we all grow up
watching the world's biggest acts
playing the super bowl and one can only
dream of being in that position i'm
humbled honored and ecstatic to be the
center of that infamous stage
this year so beautiful beautiful that's
very well said also jay-z who was tasked
by the nfl with advising on musical
events said in a press release the
weekend has a sound
all his own his soulful uniqueness has
defined a new generation of greatness in
music and artistry
this is an extraordinary moment in time
and the pepsi super bowl
lv halftime show louis vuitton halftime
show is going to be an extraordinary
experience with an extraordinary
performer
facts you know what i just thought
why does the super bowl halftime
performer
have to be pop if you think of like the
demographic of people who watch football
in america like
probably a majority country music fans
more so than pop
and you know now that i'm thinking about
it i know i slayed him for everything
but like luke holmes
should be the halftime performer like
that actually makes sense
yeah no it's weird that they're like a
country performer in a while but
in the blowfish yeah that's true
like i'm just thinking like we i i'm
we're very like there are other
genres like they they do hip hop they do
rock you know we had red hot chili
peppers so they do
they do everything except country that
yeah it would appear as though yeah but
then carrie underwood sings oh you liked
him
oh sunday night
oh sunday night
i'm real
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful oh sunday night
okay we're done um um other i i think
this is a good choice this
this is always just like this time of
year where we're selecting and talking
about this
always makes for interesting
conversation and it's interesting to see
what
has happened in the last year because
i think last year we said like ariana
grande would be great and this year like
she would be great too
yeah but i also yeah i think she would
be great i think she'll probably do it
one day but you know what just like san
francisco like this is not her year
no it's not her year um okay ready for
our next story excuse me
real housewives of new york star ramona
singer is getting a new
job yes this is actually very exciting
wow he's biting me crazy pants he's
going crazy ramona singer is moving on
from branded prinno grigio and skin care
to selling high-end real estate
the bubbly blonde is studying for her
new york real estate license a source
told gimme shelter she doesn't have it
yet but when she does she's slated to
join
michael lorber's star team at douglas
element
so i know a lot of people are probably
like confused like why she's getting a
job in real estate she's a reality star
but i think
most people who watch the show can agree
that ramona's time is
almost up and the show has been her life
for so long and
when you watch season one she had a
successful business like
reselling wholesale discounted whatever
she had like some job in fashion she had
her own business
and it was actually quite successful and
she obviously has stopped doing that and
the show became
her life and i think her income is 100
reliant on the show
and that's a very vulnerable place to be
in because i do think her time is up so
her having a job
she's very personable she's a realist
she's a
gal about town i actually think this is
a great job for her and very smart of
her to be forward thinking
about what happens after housewives
yes and i think she's going to be an
amazing real estate agent i always say
like
you you always say the word the job
you'd be worse at in this world
i think for me would be a real estate
agent but i think for a moment she's so
personable she actually
you know she appreciates real estate
she's always talking about houses and
showing off her friends houses
i think she'll be perfect at this but i
also think it's a good story line for
her on the show i don't know if she's
planning for post-show life
she's also um 60 like well until her
six-year-old is now true
she could retire oh bruno looks like
he's about to do some bidness
but i also oh he's circling gonna be oh
god should i go deal with him do you
want to oh god oh god
all right you know what maybe it's time
for a song yes please
honey time we gotta have a good time
to the sky we gonna get toasted tonight
mean you know what song i've really been
actually into is blue bert
what's called bluebird by miranda
lambert how does it go um
and if the house just keeps on winning
i got a wild card in my sleeve
and if love keeps giving me lemons
i just mix them in my oh your back sorry
that's claudia that's beautiful yeah no
i found a little um
i locked put him in you put him in the
closet okay no i put him in the kitchen
um back to ramona singer i actually
think this is great for her like it just
makes a lot of sense some people are
born for certain jobs
and i think ramona singer was meant to
be like a real estate tycoon
i totally agree i could just see her
padding around she should be on selling
sunset next if this doesn't work out
um i actually don't think ramona could
like
could cut it could compete yeah i don't
know
i don't know about her never
underestimate ramona singer never do it
okay next story some exciting news you
can rent the bachelor mansion on airbnb
for six thousand dollars a night
i saw that's kind of shocking yeah well
it's always shocking to me when i
remember that abc actually doesn't own
this house they rent it every year for a
certain amount of months from like a
family who owns it it's like a nice
family
yes the home is called the villa de la
vina it's known on the show as bachelor
mansion
it's used as a primary location for
filming the bachelor in the bachelorette
but due to the current virus pandemic
neither show is using the mansion right
now
instead they're filming at la quinta
resort in palm springs california
i guess opening it up to people renting
it also
matt james's upcoming season of the
bachelor is currently underway
and is rumored to be located in
pennsylvania i wonder where they're
filming maybe nema colon
oh i did see that a lot of bachelor
people were there but nina colan oh yeah
that's what
i just clicked the hyperlink in reality
steve is saying that they have
been posting about nema colin woodland's
resort which they went to unreal house
of potomac also and it looks incredibly
beautiful and i look forward to a change
of scenery from la quinta
i do too but pennsylvania does seem like
a random choice
i wonder why they wouldn't just film the
entire season at bachelor mansion yeah i
mean it's
ju i mean it's not it's so small
where do you do the dates yeah yeah
there's nothing in the driveway yeah
i don't know that's that's very true
yeah well i mean this is pretty cool six
thousand dollars a night seems pretty
steep
yeah it does but that's probably like a
fun thing
a fun thing to do with your friends like
a bachelorette party at bachelor mansion
no totally 16 girls what's 6 000 divided
by 16. like if you have
bruno if you have like a big
bachelorette party
okay i'm doing it on my phone a little
quick math with my new phone case
it's 375 dollars a night per person say
we'll go
we'll go two nights 7.50 per person
for two nights at the bachelor mansion
you could also have like 30 people
because that's what like they start with
and to the crew
no and the bedrooms in batcher mansion i
think they all
have bunk beds like it's literally built
for a house for 50 people oh my god we
could do like a camp toast bachelor
ranches oh that's a good idea that's
really funny
we should go oh my god bruno just tried
to [ __ ] bite me
oh yeah he's crazy pants hi sweets do
you want a stick
oh yeah
he does bite a lot i don't know what to
do magnolia did and so did theo it's
very normal
but because his teeth are like little
baby teeth they don't actually hurt
i think he got one of the caps of my
coffee cup let's see oh yeah there it is
bruno y'all just pray for us today
okay it's a busy day let's let's maybe
keep moving you know i know i'm gonna
wrap this up
i'm trying okay next up lamar odom
and sabrina parr have reunited to
celebrate the one-year anniversary of
their engagement it's just like not how
breakups work
they're splitting so the two of them are
spending time together one week after
announcing that she had broken off their
engagement
on wednesday night she posted a selfie
with lamar kissing her cheek on
instagram stories writing in the caption
made it in time to celebrate our one
year engagement anniversary
i'm gonna take this to mean that they're
back together um
which i'm happy about i'm happy about
but like what about the concerns that
she had raised
just a few days ago yeah she said um
she said something hold on where's the
quote she said y'all know i'm honest and
transparent so i have to be the first to
let you guys know
oh sorry that's the last one that she
was no longer engaged to lamar no she
said something about like people
expect you to do something you don't
always have to do what like people
expect you to do
something like that was what the gist
that i got so no i mean i'm i'm happy
for them i really am but like it seemed
like there were some like really
legitimate concerns coming from her
merely a week ago yeah and i just want
to know like were all the problems fixed
this is what she said i know society
pushes us to walk away from everyone and
everything that hurts us but the truth
is
some things are worth staying for i
agree i mean lamarr is a p
john he's honestly like the president of
peejam nation
yeah and he deserves the best so like
the fact that he's just like not
sleeping
alone makes me happy you know yes i
agree and i feel like that quote also
applies to chloe and tristan which we'll
talk about in the kardashians recap but
you know sometimes
things are what they are and you just
have to accept them speaking of
tumultuous relationships a little update
on carl
lentz the celebrity pastor's alleged
lover is
i don't know why i'm like obsessed with
this has asked us to talk about this
story a number of times this week
and finally today i had bruno i was
overwhelmed i couldn't find a fifth
story and i took advantage of her she
took advantage of my vulnerability
and she got me to report on the story
well i just can't believe like the
the mistress is very thirsty like she's
speaking directly to paychecks like not
even through like a lawyer like
this is her moment and she's gonna shine
yeah so she's talking to page six she
says
i was a drug to him she's talking about
their five-month pandemic romance and
the hypocrisy of a man
who she said was unable to practice what
he preached
she said i'm here to tell the truth and
maybe by doing that other people will
have the courage to speak up too
she said um that she was with her dog
looking for somewhere to sit
when lens offered her his circle at a
park they got to talking
they left the park together i was
telling him everything she said i
thought he's single he's a good-looking
man
why not they parted ways but he took her
phone number in the notes app on his
iphone this is like a level of detail
that i actually did not need no so
that's what i'm saying she's just like
really putting it all out there she said
the notes thing that for her was a red
flag i guess because it should have been
in his phone
um she said the next day he asked her to
save him a circle in the park
okay so like blah blah blah the two of
them got together what i thought was
really interesting was that like the
first time they hung out like
in private in her apartment she said he
was like really nervous like giving off
like teenage virgin vibes which is just
like
so mean it's just like really mean for
her to say that
she but like honestly to me what's so
weird about this whole story is like
carl lentz was a part of this like
institution where it's like they protect
like they're very private
and secretive and i just can't believe
he would just like meet a stranger in
the park and just like
have sex with her like no that's just so
messy no a hundred
percent that's not what i would have
expected from him either
so i just feel like there's no good way
to have an affair
but when you're a part of like a mega
church that is in the news a lot and
like you're very protective and you're
you know they're very closed off i was
just found it shocking that he would be
so lazy yeah like
find someone in the church like or
someone who like has
well don't cheat on your wife but if
you're gonna like don't be dumb yeah
no i feel that so that's why i wanted to
talk about it not because i'm obsessed
with carlos or anything
she is no i'm 100 obsessed with him yeah
no this story is just really crazy i
feel like every day it's like there's
something new he had just sold his house
this and that yeah and also i think
maybe why i find it so interesting is
because
i'm fascinated with people who are
famous for like we have this
conversation a lot for like their jobs
yes and like it's just not every day
that there's like famous pastors i mean
i guess actually like joel osteen is
famous and like tony robbins yeah well
he's not a pastor i don't think he's a
motivational speaker but
maybe also like um what's that guy's
name
uh um
pastor dan from uh raising helen he was
a good pastor he was a good pastor oh
you mean like from um
filthy rich yeah right so i just think
it's interesting like when people
get famous for their jobs and carlos is
one of those people and
fame is a double-edged sword my friend
yes when that you're hanging out with
justin bieber
the other you're meeting a lady in the
park selling your house
um was that our fifth time that was our
fifth and final story so now we can do
tv recap which i'm excited about because
both
great shows yes i think let's start with
keeping up with the kardashians it was
on first
um season finale bittersweet even though
like it wasn't an amazing season
it was just bittersweet because we know
what's coming
what's coming the final season like oh
yes we're moving
now we can say like with the next season
the upcoming season of kardashians is
the final season and that's just sad i
know and this season was so short they
always
are short they're like micro seasons but
this one it was short but it also had
that break in the middle remember so
it's actually been like long
i guess but it's just so strange
you told me his belly stick yeah of
course hold on sorry everyone
just let him eat as hard as it sounds i
know i guess i could just like yeah he
breaks it all you have to choose your
battles i know
you have it what i thought was really
interesting is that like during
quarantine like they were actually quite
um
busy like they were doing they were
being super safe but like they were
planning things like for courtney and
then scott's birthday
and they were together quite a bit but
like none of that was shared on social
media because like the covid police
like in the last six months like those
internet like
policemen have become so like empowered
and anything anyone does is like your
mask is not fully covering your nose
like yeah it's so crazy
and so i just find it interesting that
they had this whole life going on in
calabasas and they literally live in a
simulation like
things go on there like nobody knows
about it it's crazy and i just find it
interesting that they had
all this stuff going on and like nobody
knew about any of it yeah no
definitely really interesting also
seeing how they all
coped like kim and the four kids and we
had reported on it because she like
shared in an
interview how overwhelmed she was at the
time and we were like oh how hard it
must be
yeah but like honestly it looks
extremely overwhelming she finally got
rid of her kids and was like i miss them
so much i'm so bored like
i just i love her so much me too she was
clean like to north
get out i know like i feel like
you know of all the kids north is
probably at the age where she's like was
the most annoying and i think she has so
much energy she has so much personality
like
it must just be a lot right i know like
they have the privilege of
probably having each kid has their own
nanny in real life so to go from that
to nothing is a real shock to the system
yeah but my um this is actually last
week when we didn't recap it kim was
doing that foot peel mask that scott
gave her and me and ben did it last week
our feet
like our bed is disgusting i have to
literally vacuum the bed every day
because
so much dead skin my feet are peeling
it's like a banana like my freshness
that's the thing where you put your foot
in it and it's like a little
no like a little glovy thing yeah it's
like a foot glove
yeah and then i got one for zach a while
back it's amazing but it's like it's the
upkeep
it takes one to two weeks for all the
and what's the goal you just like get
fresh feet well i have like
really dry heels and calluses on my big
toe so just like
for the and i get them pedicured and
like exfoliated a bunch
but like for the first time in my life
like i'm literally shedding my dead skin
and it's like it's years of dead skin
that's crazy i don't i don't have
problems like that i don't think
well it's just a fun experiment it looks
really messy
it's so messy like my dust buster like
my little handheld vac has become my
best friend like
because it's just and i wear socks all
around the house now to literally
contain my dead skin that's insane it's
disgusting
that is so funny um oh sorry back to the
kardashian so
the the scott uh
rehab drama was actually very
interesting to see to watch it
unfolds because we had like reported on
it as it was happening but to see that
like no one even knew that he was there
he completely checked himself in he was
just like
trying to do what was basically himself
that just like reminds me i feel like in
a couple of the celebrity memoirs that
i've read like
celebrities will get to this breaking
point and they try to seek out help and
like
like what you would think would be best
for them and it turns out to make a
situation even worse and i'm just glad
that he has
the support system yeah that he has
because he could have gone to like a
dark place after that happened and
whatever he was feeling would have been
even more exacerbated but
i'm glad that he was able to like bounce
back from the trauma
and then they inflicted on him seeing
him on that family face time like right
after it happened i thought he would
be like a little bit like he for me if
like if that had happened to me like i
would be like destroyed i would be
embarrassed i would feel
you know exploited and i wouldn't want
to talk to anyone and i feel like he had
like kind of a good attitude about it
like they were all joking how like he
went there for trauma and they ended up
like traumatizing him like i feel like
he had like a good spirit about it
and i loved seeing rob in the family
chats like
i just i love him so much and i'm so
happy for him and i don't even want him
back on the show even though like i love
seeing him on the show
i really just want him to do like what's
best for him and dream but i just loved
seeing him and the way like
he's honestly just like he's like yeah
mom you're totally right like i just
love him
and i never see him totally really cute
um other than that the only other thing
was like tristan and chloe and
i know it's like so toxic but when i'm
watching it i'm just rooting for
for them we've never seen this much of
tristan i don't know who he was a year
ago
that he's the new man now but like the
way he was when he was talking to chris
and like talking about how like she's in
the penthouse and he's in the basement
and he's gonna like
work his way back up and even when it
gets hard he needs to look in the mirror
and be like you did this
you're here because of your mistakes
yeah i i'm just
i'm here for it i'm here for them i can
see how it would be like challenging for
chloe to like fall back into
love with him of course i trust i
i i really i ship he's doing the work
you know a year's worth of like
being a good man eating [ __ ] and being
there for her like that's
that's real stuff i know and part of me
is like i know it's toxic but like
they have a kid together and they
obviously love each other and i think
tristan
loves being a part of their family so
it's just like oh
we need to talk about kim's birthday
vlog oh i [ __ ] i didn't watch it yet oh
my god jackie
i'm sorry together like an eight minute
ig tv and it wasn't really anything
crazy it was just like footage from the
weekend where basically like all they
did was drink
and kim was actually drinking water
could you like see what she was doing
she took a shot of tequila like on
camera okay and it was just like crazy
because she really doesn't drink and
pretty much like every night they like
got drunk and stood on the beach and
like
all stood in a circle and like had a
dance circle and cory
literally went wild and did a split
and the whole crowd of people around him
tristan like they went
nuts like i don't think anyone knew that
he could do the split oh my god
it was so funny and it was like a really
like blurry like honestly like poorly
done vlog
but it was just like a real insight to
what that weekend was like and it was
like so fun and happy and i never
honestly never saw him like dance like
she was dancing with simon and phil she
wasn't dancing no i know so it was like
it was really cute i actually really
enjoyed it and i'm loving them exploring
new formats
totally oh my god i have to watch it
that sounds like such a treat i'm
obsessed with cory
me like fur obsessed like
need he's one of my favorite people on
the show and i think that honestly like
i think
him and chris have like a very very
healthy relationship i
completely agree and i love his
relationship with the girls
especially with kylie me too i'm
completely here for it and i'm
going to treat myself to that check in
the vlog i'm so excited
so funny like when he did the split
it just like came out of nowhere and it
was so
funny and that trip just looked like oh
my god i literally would have given my
right arm up just to like [ __ ] be a
part of it
um but other than that good season and i
really liked how they did all the
quarantine content i think yeah the way
that they filmed it
i can't believe that was on iphones i
know like multiple iphones but then i
was getting confused because
we knew that there was one behind them
showing their conversation and one in
front of them they showed us how they
set it up but then the one in front of
them
when they would show us like that angle
we never the camera behind them wasn't
there so
i saw the camera behind there many times
but many times i didn't
like when that was just like angles no
but like i guess
yeah maybe maybe oh maybe they don't
okay i really hope that they like
every single one of them like gives it
their all for the final season like
i want rob kendall kylie like i want
everyone
giving their all like making this an
amazing season because
i'm really sad like that it's coming to
an end i know
but i just am holding out hope that the
new whatever is next
that there's more show just a different
provider and format
et cetera also i think the most
interesting thing about um watching them
in quarantine was seeing all of their
natural hair
yeah kim's is really short chloe's is
short and blonde
and courtney's is short too yeah i just
thought that was really interesting
because they're always like wearing wigs
and extensions chloe had like
amazing nails the whole time like the
claws
yeah so i wonder how she did that i
don't know um
and then southern charm which was good i
mean i'm just so in love with john
pringle and i just like
really am rooting for him in madison
you're in love with him i think
i think only as it pertains to madison
like he's definitely acting
inappropriately because like she's fully
in a relationship but like
you know i think i've come to the
conclusion that like maybe her and
austin just like are not otp
oh i think that they are otp but i think
uh um
i don't i don't mind what john pringle
is doing because i think it will
make awesome step up more and be more of
what madison deserves but like i really
do think that
madison and austin are otp like they
just can't quit each other
i really love catherine for two reasons
one she's the only person who points out
how bizarre it is that like patricia is
like
having such a heavy hand and everything
like making comments to madison about
her relationship with austin when it's
like
katherine's the only one who's literally
saying like this is like an 80 year old
woman like why is she getting involved
in your relationship
when she was like it's like we're on the
instant cover and she's the one holding
the puppets at the top and it's like
that's exactly what she's doing and
even though catherine and patricia
aren't in a good place so you would
think like catherine wouldn't want to
cross patricia or like say something
like that no but like
she's not crossing her she's just saying
the obvious
and the other thing i really loved about
catherine which happened last week was
when leva like just
really confronted her like hands down
like you cannot say the [ __ ] about
cameron like she was very unapologetic
and i
really agreed with catherine and the way
that she handled that whole situation
it's like
why is everyone allowed to say anything
they want about me and madison like
we're just like
the ex like the uh what's the word
exception yeah sure that works like
they're just the exceptions but if
anyone says anything about anyone else
like
it's like how could you say that like
and i just i and you know what
even though everyone loves her and i
liked her too like cameron was
for like the last eight years like
really the the potster like and just
like the mover of pieces
and also she was so influential in the
group that if she had been
more sympathetic towards catherine
everyone else would have been but like
yeah
and so you don't get eight years on a
show with she literally had eight years
on a show and never
once never met her husband like so
surface level whereas like catherine's
literally bleeding out with her custody
cases and thomas getting a girl pregnant
like
so much and it's just like if i were
katherine i would be pissed too and i
would just say whatever the [ __ ] i
wanted
and it's worth noting that catherine did
not make that rumor up because i heard
it too like a year ago
yeah no but i guess lava was just upset
with her for repeating it and
which i i hear you being a good friend
lova but it's like do you know what's
gone on here for the last seven years
yeah for sure but she's just you like
seeing it from her perspective
i absolutely love leba me too like with
every passing episode last week i
watched and that was like my note for
the week like i love her i love her
businesses are
so impressive so impressive so
interesting her son's name is little
which i think is the cutest thing ever
she's calling him little and like
that's like like lil and then his name
popped up on the screen i'm like i love
that name
me too um do you have a piece of tape on
your shirt
what do you mean this yeah is that
design or oh i thought it was part of
the
because shirt no it's vitamins so i'm
like they just do weird stuff oh leave
it
actually no no it might be it might be
if it's vitamins believe it definitely
not
are you sure okay it's definitely not um
yes by the way i totally agree with leva
i'm with you about love like i loved her
i thought her businesses were
so impressive like and how they all
talked about republic how like it
literally changed the social scene in
charleston like they don't even remember
life before republic i just thought that
was like so impressive that her and her
husband did that
and i just like love people who go on um
reality shows and are so proud of their
culture and i think that's why like i
love shaw's of sunset so much because
you learn so much and it's just like
cool to see people who are so
proud of where they came from and i
loved it like in charleston where i'm
sure there's like
no persian people she was just like so
proud of her cooking and her mom and
it was just i love people who do that so
i actually this episode really made me
like leva
when i was like a little turned off to
her when she was just like so aggressive
to catherine last week
but i'll actually like and and i liked
her comfort even though i
probably agree with i hear they see
where catherine's coming from i really
liked leva's confrontation style like
she just
was said it like it was like no holds
barred and i think that even though
katherine like felt the way that she did
she was like okay
like oh yeah stood up she was like i'm
not going to keep going down this road
yeah you know um also i just like need
new york to open up one of those bars
where your dogs can run around like oh
my god what the hell was that i need
that
i had so much anxiety when danny's dog
was in the mud because like it's a white
flying dog like
but they were having so much fun it
really bothers me to check shep's dog's
name is craig
i know it's so rude it just like harks
back to when shep was the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and like to name your dog after your
best friend is like so
nasty no i agree and it's like part of
me like really
does try so hard to see the best in chap
like he didn't know peter and madison
[ __ ] like part of me like
really really but part of me like just
can't because
he's like the worst you know i know i
feel like
i'm making strides he's making strides
and i really liked his conversation with
madison by the way like madison i don't
know why everyone keeps starting with
madison i know it's like
she's the last person i would want to
confirm she comes out on top so
on point like ever she just she will
roast
don't start with her i agree because she
will finish it yeah
finish you she'll finish after years of
shep just like going after everyone on
the show and everyone's sort of just
like
cowering and and scurrying away like
she's like
nah [ __ ] you and yeah define your
relationship yeah no i love her
i i love her i think she's a wonderful
reality television
and a great woman um so yeah
i think that was it oh i did watch um
the real housewives of salt lake city on
watch robin's live i caught up on watch
rap and live yesterday
first of all the episode with darius
rucker and reba was absolutely
incredible like i recommend everyone
watching it was just like a great
night to be a bravo fan and a pop
culture fan and auntie did this segment
is
how fancy is reba and it was like
because she's like so rich like when was
the last time you flew commercial like
all these questions it was great
when was it last year um and even darius
rucker was like wow really
um then the real housewives of salt lake
city were on it was so messy like
everyone and their tech problems like
mary's camera was like literally on the
floor and at least it was so blurry like
but i it was interesting to see them in
that setting i agreed
jen shaw is my queen heather is my queen
and
i'm it's unfortunately just gonna be
like a big fat note for me from lisa
is that her name i get lisa meredith
confused sorry explain why
she was giving oh you were right she was
giving off like very um
premeditated like i've been waiting my
whole life for this moment
yes and like even just her look and
everything and like andy and like she
just tries like
she's like like putting herself in the
housewife's hemisphere like even though
she's literally been here for two years
she has one photo from
the party with bethany and she was like
i met her i'm so happy for her and her
empire no it's like you literally met at
a party
once seven years ago and you're proud of
her like it was just
very thirsty so i totally saw what you
saw but you definitely planted it in my
head like oh for sure which i can do and
did you like meredith moore on watch
what happened live
yes oh my god so meredith got something
done like lip filler or something that
made her look way different
than lisa she was giving me like kyle
richards vibe which was very helpful i
need her to continue filling up her face
and yes she wasn't so thirsty it was
like andy would ask a question and there
were certain people like
jen who were like heather who like
literally could not wait to answer the
question and lisa was just like
meredith was just like i will speak when
spoken to like she was very relaxed and
not thirsty and whitney too
and mary because i don't think mary had
any idea what was going on like yeah she
was just not present she couldn't figure
out like she couldn't hear anything like
she was not there but um
some of them were really thirsty and
some of them were not like and i just
thought that was interesting
i thought it was interesting the
question that andy asked about like how
does the town
the city of salt lake city and you know
the mormon community feel about the show
and lisa was like they love it like
everyone's so happy that housewives are
here she's talking about herself so fans
then heather was like i couldn't
disagree with you more and heather is
like
really connected to like the core like
legit parts of the church and like she
would know yeah and also i just feel
like lisa is just saying how she feels
like we love it we're so happy for
ourselves are here
um so it was a really busy week of
television watching i'm honestly
relieved that it's over like i know
i guess next week without cmas like we
get three hours back
and no kardashians because
kardashians no kardashians because this
was the season finale so four hours back
next week
yeah no premieres though oh please well
you know
total bella started again but i didn't
watch um
i didn't watch but sometimes i do i
don't know i really like that show and
like sometimes i catch one episode and
then i like
fly through the scene right well i'm
actually thinking maybe i'm not gonna
watch tv this weekend because that's
literally all i did and crown drop
no way two days november 15th that
is very exciting yeah that just oh look
bruno sweets the crowd
clown my boy hi my sweetie pie so we're
gonna wrap this up
thank you bruno for being here everyone
follow bruno on instagram at pups with
no job
and thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennium
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories every monday through friday
that you need to know
wait no i [ __ ] that up thank you so
much for listening to the morning shows
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every morning monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us some morning toast and
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
hope you have an amazing weekend stay
safe don't drink and drive have a good
time
wear a face mask and we'll see you
[Music]
tomorrow
hey